aquí tenemos tres definiciones de
funciones diferentes tenemos fx que está
en azul tenemos este mapeo de valores de
'the age' dt así que lo podemos ver como
la definición de gt y aquí
veamos de x a hdx cuando x es igual a 3
hd x va a ser igual hacer cuando x es
igual a 1 hd x va a ser igual a 2 1 2 3
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducirlos a la idea de composición
de funciones a qué me refiero con esto
de composición de funciones significa
construir una función usando otras
funciones o podrían pensar que estamos
anidando funciones poniendo funciones
dentro de otras funciones qué significa
esto
vamos a imaginarnos cómo sería evaluar
efe pero no va a ser
fx vamos a comenzar con un ejercicio
sencillito
vamos a evaluar efe de g
de 2 efe deje dedos que creen ustedes
que va a resultar aquí y los invitó a
que pausa en el vídeo para que piensen
en ello por su cuenta podría verse un
poquito complicado al principio sobre
todo si no están familiarizados con la
anotación que presentamos acá pero
simplemente tenemos que recordar que es
una función una función es simplemente
un mapeo de un conjunto de números hacia
otro conjunto de números por ejemplo
cuando decimos g de dos lo que estamos
haciendo es tomar el 2 y ponerlo como
entrada de la función g que aquí vamos a
dibujar como un cuadrito y después
tendremos una salida que vamos a llamar
g de 2 y ahora vamos a usar esa salida
como entrada pero de nuestra función
efe ahora entonces tomamos g de 2 como
entradas de la función f que aquí
también ponemos como cuadrito efe y
tendremos como resultado como salida
efe dg de 2 que fue lo que pusimos como
entrada g de 2 fue nuestra entrada
fg de 2 ahora analicemos esto paso por
paso que es g de 2 bueno
27 va a ser igual a menos 3 obtenemos
como salida menos 3 y ahora pongo menos
3 como entrada de la función f entonces
voy a la función f y que voy a obtener
bueno mi entrada aquí la tomo como x
entonces tengo menos 3 al cuadrado menos
uno menos tres al cuadrado menos que es
nueve menos uno igual a ocho esto es
igual a ocho efe vg de dos es 8
usando la misma lógica que nos dará la
función f de hd2
efe de f de hd2 y de nuevo los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y piensen en ello
por ustedes mismos bueno
pensemos los de esta manera en lugar de
resolverlo usando este tipo de diagramas
aquí cada vez que veamos una x la vamos
a sustituir por lo que tengamos de
entrada de la función así que no importa
qué entrada tengamos la vamos a elevar
al cuadrado y le vamos a restar 1 aquí
la entrada es hd 2 y por lo tanto
tomamos de entrada a hd 2 la elevamos al
cuadrado y ya que le elevamos al
cuadrado le restamos 1 así que efe dh de
2 es igual a hd 2 al cuadrado menos 1
ahora que es hd 2 cuando x es igual a 2
hd 2 va a ser igual a 1 así que hd 2 es
bueno y ya que sabemos cuál es este
valor pues lo sustituimos acá hd2 es 1 y
eso se simplifica como 1 al cuadrado
sigue siendo uno menos 1 va a ser igual
a ser 1 menos uno es
a 0 y también pudimos haberlo resuelto
usando estos diagramas pudimos haber
dicho bueno voy a tomar como entrada 2
para la función h aquí está mi cuadrito
de función h
si tenemos como entrada 2 en h vamos a
tener como resultado un 1 este es h 21
esto es hd 2 y ahora pondremos esto como
entrada en f esto entra a la función f y
nos dará como salida o como resultado f
de uno es igual a uno al cuadrado menos
uno que es igual a uno menos uno iba a
hacer y esto de aquí es
efe dh de dos así que la salida es el
resultado de nuestra entrada en la
función
efe efe de hd2 y ahora podemos ir un
poquito más lejos vamos a componer tres
de éstas vamos a usar tres de estas
funciones juntas vamos a ver qué se me
ocurre vamos a tomar
vamos a cambiar el orden de f
d
de f2 y ahora permítanme pensar un
poquito esto para que nos dé un
resultado interesante y esto va a ser la
entrada de h
entonces nos va a quedar h deje de f2
nada más por diversión
ahora tenemos una composición triple hay
varias formas de resolver esto una de
ellas es tratar de evaluar que nos da f
2 regresamos a nuestras funciones y f 2
es 2 al cuadrado menos 12 por 24 menos 1
372 va a ser igual a 3 así que esto de
aquí la función que está hasta dentro es
3 y ahora que es g de 3 bueno vamos a
regresar a las funciones y cuando te es
igual a 3 gmt es igual a 4 así que todo
esto a su vez es 4g de 3 todo esto de
acá es 4 f de 2 3 g de 34 ahora que nos
da hd 4 vemos que aquí está x 4 hd 4 es
igual a menos 1 así que h de g
efe de 2 es igual a menos 1 espero que
esto nos ayude a familiarizarse con este
concepto de como evaluar la composición
de funciones